so Barry why do you think iris wanted
you to to see me today
well we recently started working
together you canceled training the other
day without asking me training swimming
it's a triathlon we're not on the same
page people could die like if they
crashed into a brick wall going 100
miles per hour metaphorically the weight
of the whole city falls on my shoulders
I'm the flash
[Applause]
[Music]
I trust you Irish
in run Barry run we would support
you would start running I gotta go
Souths er what is it
Cisco figured it out he figured out how
to crack Barry's code you did what does
it say hold on one sec it's loading
come on loading loading loading loading
and it says this house is spittin
alright hey everybody this is gonna be
my flash DC TV Q&A video also includes
stuff from the other DC TV shows but
we'll start with Flash stuff there's a
little bit of crossover updates that
we've gotten Stephen Amell has even been
making some jokes and posting some
pictures from behind the scenes so I'll
start with that stuff as you saw
Constantine is coming back on the shows
so I'll explain that too but I'm - do
this in a slightly different way than I
would normally do Q&A videos there's a
new round of that Justice League ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video on that's a new winner at the end
of this so a lot of you been messaging
me with pictures from behind the scenes
of the earth X version of all the
crossover characters so like Stephen
Amell just posted this picture it's of
somebody in the pipeline he sort of
greened it out so you can't see who it
is but you see a little corner of the
suit here so he said it's a scene that
he's been waiting this whole time to
film and this suit kind of looks like
his doppelgangers there are a lot of you
that want this to be Tommy I don't know
if Tommy is going to be a part of the
earth X crossover because Colin Donnell
is still series regular on his TV show
so if by some act of God they were able
to schedule that and it were to work it
would be really cool so just whoever he
is in here this is supposed to be a
really really big scene from the
crossover so I'm not expecting to see an
actual trailer for those episodes till
the beginning of November but relatively
soon very soon they're almost done
filming so moving into the flash I just
try to take some of the biggest
questions that you guys were asking
after the first episode so the first one
is is what's up with wall-e running
around with dyed hair not being in the
flash episodes like he has purple hair
here very clearly he's not on the set
the thing is is he's probably just not a
big part of the crossover episode so
he'll come back when he's done with this
yes he did appear on legends of tomorrow
but the big surprise there is that it
was actually in the first episode and it
was just a really small thing inside
central city so that was really more
about citizens steal help filling in the
gap while Barry was gone in that six
month period between seasons not so much
about Wally going on another TV show so
when he does come back I think it will
be to the flash I think part of the
reason why they're not doing a lot more
speedsters this season is so that they
can focus more on his character
development and obviously they've kind
of recycled the big speedster villain
every season up until now but the next
big one is is what about that gibberish
that Barry said he said a number of
things that have happened in the past so
scenes that they've had in previous
seasons but he also said I didn't kill
anybody your honor so I will do a
separate video about this because it's a
bit of an easter egg for the
reverse-flash if your big comic book fan
you probably remember the trial of the
flash where Barry gets put on trial in
the distant future for the death of the
reverse-flash reverse-flash was trying
to kill his girlfriend so he snapped his
neck Zod style but the Legion of
super-heroes took him to the future and
he had to stand trial
so that was way back during the Silver
Age it'll probably be different when
they do it on this show but if you
remember way back during season one when
he went back for the first time to try
and save his mother he saw all those
visions killer frost the flash Museum he
also saw a picture of himself in iron
Heights prison wearing prison clothing
meaning that he had been sent to prison
for some reason that might be what that
line of dialogue was about Your Honor I
didn't kill anybody but as for the
writing a lot of you have also noticed
that the writing on the thinker's face
is the same as the symbols that Barry's
been writing down and it's also tattooed
on this thugs hand so when they decoded
the symbols Cisco was like this house is
bitchin
it didn't work I think the twist is is
that it did work and Barry has just seen
everything that's going to happen this
season and try to write it down the only
way he knew how but they don't know how
to interpret that yet like look at the
symbol on the back of the thinker's
chair here that actually looks like a
lot of the symbols here so the secret to
defeating the thinker is in these
symbols there's a message somehow that
will explain what's going to
and they just need to learn to decode
that but a lot of you were asking about
Danny Trejo is he going to be a villain
is he going to be good I think they're
playing it more for comedy and he is a
villain in this episode but not
ultimately a villain like he's just a
dad that really cares about his daughter
Cisco will probably win him over by the
end of the episode but a lot of you big
comic-book fans will know that breacher
in the comics definitely was a villain I
don't think they're gonna do it exactly
like it was in the comics I think they
could always bring him back as a villain
but I just think for the purposes of
this episode it's just for the
relationship comedy the other big
question I saw from you guys that I was
really surprised by was people asking
about Barry getting drunk because of
this picture here he's in a bar this
actually seems like it's from Barry's
bachelor party and yes he can get drunk
with a really special alcohol but the
whole idea here is that I think he's
just celebrating and he's just really
happy so he seems like he's drunk
so the actual bachelor party won't take
place till episode 5 that's the episode
that Katee Sackhoff has guests starting
it she's playing Amunet black the
blacksmith they actually named her
during episode 1 she's the person that
Caitlin's been working for during this
past six month period but we can talk
more about her in a separate video
that's still a couple weeks away
probably the other biggest question was
people wondering what was going on with
Iris in the trailer for episode 2 saying
you're not the flash were the flash
she's talking about the team together so
it's called the flash family for a
reason because Barry does better when he
has a family around them and team flash
right now is that family but they
actually do have a legit comic book
flash family - it's just that they're
not doing so many speedsters right now
the deal with Constantine is that he's
crossing over two legends of tomorrow
doing at least one episode he'll perform
an exorcism inside and a sane asylum but
beyond that I don't know how they're
going to use them that's all they've
said about him so far but he does have
an animated show that you'll be able to
watch for free on CW seed but they
haven't announced a premiere date for
that yet but it's on the CW c-calm
moving into arrow territory a lot of you
were asking why diggle's hands were
shaking and why he can't hit anything
with his gun the whole thing is that
they have PTSD everyone's just
expressing it in different ways so all
this
is is just shock from what happened back
on the island when Prometheus blew them
all up he just hasn't dealt with it yet
the person at the end of the episode
everyone was asking about who seemingly
rescued black siren because she's alive
in present day is probably going to turn
out to be Michael Emerson if you look at
this silhouette here he has here the
actor playing Richard dragon is bald on
the TV show so I'm just assuming that's
him and it sounds like all the big
things that happen at the end of the
episode the big WTF were through his
actions so black siren is doing stuff
for him but because I didn't have time
to get to a Legends video the big thing
they tease this season the big villain
is called malice they haven't revealed
who that is or whether or not it's a
person from the comics there is a comic
book character called malice he's from
the irredeemable Mark Waid comic book
which is not canon to DC Comics so there
is no DC Comics character called malice
which makes me think that it's either
the name of the team of villains or it's
a person who they just created for the
TV show but they're bringing damian
darhk-- back Gorilla Grodd will be one
of the villains and then the last one
that I know about will be kuwasa
who's one of vixens granddaughters and
as far as I know the current version of
vixen is still on the TV show but she
went back to the past so presumably
she'll rejoin the team eventually but
what will probably happen is is because
there's so much stuff that happens in
the middle of the week I don't know if
I'm gonna do regular legends of tomorrow
videos I might just do videos for the
big stuff for the crossover the
mid-season finale the big finale
episodes and when it comes back so I'll
still do legend stuff so no worries if
there's videos that I'm not doing but
you have big questions about you can ask
them for the Q&A videos and I'll include
them so the next flash video that I'll
probably do will be for all that
gibberish that Barry spoke and probably
a new trailer video - we actually
supposedly saw elongated man in one of
those but we actually found that he's
coming in Episode four so that should be
coming in the next couple of days if I
have time for tonight I'll get to it but
there's new Game of Thrones tomorrow
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Matthew Lopez please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details while
you wait for everything you can click
here for the trailer for the next flash
episode and you can click here for brand
new Rick and Morty thank you so much for
watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight